artificial intelligence is bringing in a
new era of Medicine
algorithms combined with Advanced
robotics can Aid everything from
Diagnostic Imaging and Analysis to
remote surgical assistance and even
autonomously performed procedures
the data collected by Rehabilitation
devices and Prosthetics could also
improve individualized recovery in
patients in the July special issue of
science experts offered Insight on how
these extraordinary advances bring hope
for more consistent and effective
treatment in the future
the future of surgery is likely to
include robots with some ability to work
on their own
surgical robots are classified by their
level of autonomy and the degree to
which they use algorithms to make
medical decisions
level zero robots have no autonomy and
rely on a human operator to perform
surgical procedures
level 1 robots make use of AI to provide
assistance with procedures but still
relies on human control
at level 2 robots have autonomy over
certain tasks repetitive or tedious
subtasks within a procedure like cutting
cancerous tissues are assigned by
surgeons to the robot
conditional autonomy at level 3 involves
robots generating a strategy or list of
strategies for a task but still relies
on a human to select or approve the
strategy the smart tissue autonomous
robot operates at this level applying
machine learning to generate and execute
a plan for suturing
this is currently the highest level of
autonomy possible with today's
technology but advances on the horizon
may bring us closer to fully autonomous
systems
image guided robotics combine computer
vision with images from cameras
ultrasound MRI or CT scans to identify
key anatomy and precisely direct robots
to targets
early applications of AI and image
guided robots were focused on steering
needles through soft tissues to reach
targets for biopsies
now attention is moved on leveraging AI
to understand images on a higher level
and make more accurate navigational
decisions
interpreting images on a fine scale and
changing course based on that
information could lead to autonomous
ultrasound scanning or self-guided
maneuvering of devices for endoscopies
and minimally invasive surgeries
a significant challenge that remains is
the high level of expertise required
from Radiologists and surgeons to train
the algorithms that control this
technology
still robotic systems that can see and
interpret their surroundings are likely
to have a more prominent role in the
future of Medical Care
surgical technology already uses robots
to assist in minimally invasive
surgeries but the rigid components of
current surgical robots limit access to
certain areas of the body and in some
cases can cause tissue injuries
researchers have been exploring the
potential for Soft Robotics made of
pliable materials that can stretch Bend
compress and shift from soft to rigid
one notable project was the EU stiff
flop project
stiff flop developed a soft robotic
system from biocompatible silicone that
used Advanced machine learning for its
teleoperation
it remains an open question whether Soft
Robotics will develop the Precision
needed for intricate surgical
applications or whether traditional
surgical robots will acquire some of the
properties of soft robotic technology
wearable robots could transform the
rehabilitation experience for both
patients and health professionals
hard mechanical exoskeletons and soft
robotic exosuits already in development
can improve patient outcomes and offer
the assistance needed to get back to
daily life
the transformative potential for these
wearable robots however comes from the
data that they can collect the ability
to continuously track movement and
adjust robotic assistance based on
personal progress could revolutionize
Rehabilitation but the challenge in
these systems is in the calibration of
devices that separate signals of
recovery from noise in the data sensor
placement day-to-day fit of devices and
regular variability and how patients
bodies feel and function are among the
many complicating factors in developing
generalized algorithms to allow
widespread use of wearable robots
artificial intelligence is tightening
the relationship between robotic
prostheses and their users
machine learning algorithms allow
robotic limbs to sense intended motion
through neuromuscular signals enabling
more seamless control of prosthetic
hands and motorized lower limbs
this relationship is developing even
further with Machine Vision designed to
sense the surrounding environment
prosthetic legs that can see upcoming
terrain can help the user adapt to their
environment
these advances have the potential to
restore and enhance prosthetic users
abilities to complete everyday tasks
in addition to meeting high standards
for safety developers will also have to
gain users trust in the idea of AI
enabled limbs
as Medical Technology continues to
develop artificial intelligence will
play an expanding role in how we
diagnose treat and understand the human
body
[Music]